she's not saying that she's saying the
attitude that people have to say that
women should just be mothers and your
motherhood is the most important no wait
wait wait that's wait yeah yeah when
she's trying to really say is that
attitude that you say that that's what
women are for what they are about makes
it look like we're just like little
what'd you call the house
the dog girl uh is that what you
call it female dogs no one said that
word I see you starting to realize this
you're the Jesus Lover over here hold on
you're starting to realize the mindset
that a lot of these women have they're
comparing motherhood to being bred like
a cow I feel like it's just very